car le deuxième bébé on est toutes un
bain beauté ses parents de la communauté
de lac barrière en outaouais en ont
arraché leur dépendance les empêchait de
bien s'occuper de leurs enfants
la dpj a dû intervenir les arabes un
blanc de quoi éveiller de douloureux
souvenirs
le père craignait de voir ses enfants
subir les mêmes traitements qu'elle
avait vécu sa propre mère dans les
pensionnats indiens au pays plus de
trois et demi pour cent des autochtones
de moins de 15 ans sont en famille
d'accueil
ces douze fois plus que dans le reste de
la population c'est un communautés
affectées maquis vis des grandes
difficultés la direction de la
protection de la jeunesse en outaouais
n'a pas attendu le rapport de la
commission pour agir la grande grande
majorité des enfants autochtones qui ne
sont pas avec leurs parents pour
l'instant sont avec des personnes
significatives de leur communauté ou
avec des familles d'accueil autochtone
depuis trois ans lorsqu'un enfant
autochtone est retiré de son milieu
familial les proches sont consultés
avant de faire appel à une famille
d'accueil
même si tes poches chez tes parents te
quand même dans la communauté
puis c'est ce qui est important que tout
accord chez toi pour l'intervenante
monique chabot
il faut aussi que les autochtones
reprennent confiance parce qu'on sait
qu'ils connaissent dans science a là un
vide les habilités parentales
je sais des gens qui savaient pas
comment est un peu
donc aujourd'hui quand tu peux dire est
une bonne mère
c'est un bon père c'est juste des
comportements il a fallu du temps pour
que le couple règle ses problèmes de
dépendances les enfants ont été pris en
charge à deux reprises la deuxième fois
cette approche était en place ça nous
change de statut en faillite et tous se
portent mieux
la famille réunie elle se dit même prête
à devenir à son tour parents d'accueil
dans la réserve ici madeleine blé morin
radio-canada maniwaki